hervé nathan on voit là le la difficulté
de ce genre de pratique ces
dénonciations publiques mais c'est
parole contre parole
oui c'est très très compliqué en général
d'abord c'est parole contre parole donc
on est obligé de donner la parole aux
deux et d'écouter les deux là seul moyen
qu'on voit éventuellement de trancher à
celui très frileux c'est d'être en chine
le vrai du faux
ce serait éventuellement un procès en
diffamation parce que je suis ne trompe
pas c'est prescrit donc ça pourrait
pause on va se retrouver la situation
qu'on a vu dans d'autres affaires où il
ya une prescription donc ne pas juger le
fait lui-même donc on va juger si ces
diffamations ou pas en général c'est pas
bon pour les victimes en tout cas celle
qui se présente tel c'est à ce parent ça
se termine assez mal donc c'est pas une
solution
je pense que ce n'est pas une solution
le problème du hashtag qui est pour moi
était un mouvement d'opinion
extraordinaire je suis pour ton port
parce que tout d'un coup on se rend
compte de la profondeur de du mal qui
est fait aux deux qui fait aux femmes
voilà tout d'un coup non non elle
débarque dans des bars pas complètement
mais le haut ce que je voulais essayer
c'est qu' un moment il ya bien une forme
d'impasse faire que ça c'est un
mouvement d'opinion et ça permet de
poser le problème parce que peut-être on
ne pousse pas assez souvent et c'est
sans doute ça qui fait qui à mon avis
est un problème est que mais moi je
pense que par ailleurs la
judiciarisation il ya des limites à sa
d'abord parce que c'est très difficile
pour les victimes
ça se termine pas forcément bien pour le
moment les tribunaux sont pas forcément
favorables regardez ce qui est arrivé il
ya une histoire à l'assemblée nationale
elle est terminé et maintenant c'est
c'est l'ancien c'est le député hommes
qui portent plainte pour diffamation
parce que comme c'est prescrit en
maintenant des coûts bien plus corsée
voilà on peut même plus par 1 go et même
plus en parler
par ailleurs moi j'ai puisqu'on a fait
un dossier elle suce moi je suis j'ai
quelque chose qui m'a un peu interloqué
c'est que il ya une demande de
judiciarisation énorme et donc de
sanction de répression de très forte
c'est sans doute justifiée et il ya une
permissivité de la société et des
pouvoirs politiques sur 1,52 choses qui
sont pour moi des faits générateurs du
harcèlement sexuel je parle de la
pornographie sur internet je signale que
les enfants arrivent à accéder à 8 ans 9
ans 10 ans 11 ans il accède à la
pornographie sur internet on va pas
faire un tableau ce que c'est que la
pornographie sur internet c'est un appel
au viol c'est le dire le corps des
femmes est disponible aux hommes c'est
grosso modo ça c'est des cd vidéo de 3
minutes il se louer peut-être le rap
aussi non mais je vais pas voilà donc il
y a en tout cas il ya des lois en france
sur la protection des mineurs certains
ils sont maintenant je suis allé voir au
programme et ça on les applique pas le
professeur israël nisand que le
gynécologue obstétricien et président du
collège français d une comme ça ça fait
des années qu'il est là dessus il a
essayé d'alerter les pouvoirs publics
personne n'a rien fait parce que ça
c'est pas chic
ça fait c'est pas bien lieu de celle pas
chic d'aller d'aller d'aller regarder ce
qui se passe sur internet et surtout de
dire on va verrouiller il demande un
truc très simple il y est qu'à exiger le
paiement à la première image en disant à
la première image pornographique pour
l'avoir il faut mettre là qu'il faut
donner son numéro de carte bleue
ça ce serait efficace et très simple à
faire c'est beaucoup plus simple qu'on
pense et ça personne ne le propos tient
tout d'un coup il ya plus personne
mais il ya une génération entière qui
est en train d'apprendre sur internet
qu'on peut violer les femmes et que ça
leur fait du bien parce que c'est ça ce
qui se passe sur internet ans